on va en parler karen mulder interview
vérité
[Applaudissements]
alors karen mulder aux côtés de naomi
campbell de cindy crawford de claudia
schiffer de linda evangelista et de elie
mcpherson vous avez été donc une star
des podiums avait fait la une de tous
les grands magazines du monde c'était
l'époque des top models qu'est ce qu'un
top model avait de plus quand même qu'un
normal en fait c'était un mot qui est
tout d'un coup est remonté à la surface
et tout d'un coup on était plus des
mannequins et on était des top models et
je crois que c'était les filles qui
étaient vraiment sur le devant de la
scène qui était pas seulement des les
files sur des couvertures mais qui
convoyait à la télévision connaissent
elles en ont leur nid en fait la
célébrité quoi ouais alors ensuite vous
avez quitté le métier vous avez fait des
voyages aux caraïbes
vous avez fait la tournée des [ __ ]
vous avez fait des tentatives déjà pour
enregistrer un disque pour jouer la
comédie et puis un soir ici sur ce
plateau vous avez avait craqué c'était
en fait des choses qui sont remontés à
la surface qui ont fait que tout d'un
coup il y avait de la paranoïa en plus
mais il y avait des choses vraies
ensuite vous avez passé trois mois en
clinique à lutter contre la dépression
et aujourd'hui vous êtes de retour et
vous dites je me sens une autre femme
toute neuve la même en mieux bah oui on
change un petit peu des personnalités je
crois que quand on va chercher très loin
dans soi mais on est toujours la même
personne mais oui mieux je suis plus
serein je vis plus l'instant avant
j'avais toujours tendance à les regarder
en arrière d'être nostalgique ou avoir
toujours un but
regarder vers le futur et aujourd'hui je
vis vraiment au jour le jour quoi mais
est ce que cette souffrance vous endurci
est ce que vous sentez plus forte
qu'avant
je crois toujours être quelqu'un de très
fort d'un côté et très fragile de notre
la souffrance de appris la compassion ma
souffrance a toujours été là pendant ma
vie c'était quelque chose donc je lutter
constamment contre donc je suis toujours
été quelqu'un qui avait eu beaucoup de
compassion maintenant vous avez connu le
meilleur de la vie le pire vous savez
tout mais on sait jamais tout
est ce que les psys vous ont vraiment
aidé dans cette affaire et j'en ai vu
des des abrutis excuse moi le mot si il
y en a vraiment ils ont rien compris du
tout et là je
oui j'en ai un que je vois de temps en
temps je le vois même pas souvent parce
que j'ai plus besoin mais j'aime bien de
temps en temps pour remettre les
pendules à l'heure et
quelque part aussi je pense qu'on a
manqué dans son éducation où la vie ne
nous a pas appris ils voulaient
expliquent lui vous juge pas au moins
ils écoutent
alors vous êtes passés de l'autre côté
du miroir vous savez maintenant que le
bonheur n'est plus obligatoirement lié à
l'argent à la gloire à la vie facile
mais peut-être à l'amour c'est un amour
des tâches et moi c'est un amour où
on s'approprie pas quelque chose ou
quelqu'un c'est quelque chose de plus
spirituel pour moi
j'espérais rencontrer l'homme de votre
vie karen j pense pas ouais oui parce
que si vous y pensez ça va vous obliger
à vous alerter dans le secteur ouest
et qu'il faut pas avoir une idée trop
trop préconçues non plus faut pas avoir
une idée en tête parce que sinon on
n'est plus disponible pour les hommes
qui peuvent arriver ben oui c'est vrai
que par la solitude des fois on fait les
mauvais choix on préfère être avec
quelqu'un même s'il nous convient pas
tout à fait parce qu'on veut pas le seul
ou des choses comme ça oui
quel type d'homme vous cherchez mais je
cherche pas
quel type d'homme vous aimeriez
rencontrer alors
j'aimerais quelqu'un
je trouve ça très difficile peut-être un
homme tout simple oui
voulait avoir des enfants ah oui
j'aimerais beaucoup mais pour ça il
faudra quand même que je trouve ça fun
ça vous demande un effort d'être là ce
soir non non non très loin derrière
lewis urgent de faire faire du tout de
venir ici
non mais c'était vraiment très aimable
de pas l'avoir déficit c'est la moindre
des choses
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
eux